ما كان في عهد صدام ليس كما قبله أو بعده،
الجيش العراقي
من رابع أقوى الجيوش في العالم،
إلى أضعف الجيوش في العالم،
تتلاعب به داعش كيفما شاءت،
فتساقطت في يدها المحافظات كالأوراق،
فكيف لو استعملت أمريكا ورقة داعش في عهد صدام،
كان جيش يحمي الدولة وتهابه الدول،
فكيف أصبح اليوم؟
ومالفرق بين جيش العراق في عهد صدام
والجيش العراقي اليوم؟...
عندما صعد صدام حسين للسلطة عام ١٩٧٩،
كان الجيش قبله، يخرج من انقلاب ويدخل آخر،
لكن قبل أن يصعد صدام للرئاسة
كان قد بنى نظاما عسكريا قويا جدا،
وحين أمسك بزمام الأمور في الحكم،
بدأ بتطوير الجيش ومواكبة الجيوش الغربية،
من حيث العدد والسلاح، وتم تصنيف الجيش العراقي حينها،
كرابع أقوى الجيوش في العالم،
بعد الاتحاد السوفييتي وأمريكا وبريطانيا،
وكان اقوى جيش بين الدول العربية والإسلامية،
وبلغ عدد أفراده، مليون جندي،
وكان الجيش يتكون حينها، من ٣٥٠ألف جندي
في القوات البرية، فيها ١٠٠ألف من جنود الاحتياط،
وتتكون القوات البرية من سبعة فيالق وثلاث فرق مُدرعة
و11 فرقة ميكانيكية وست فرق من قوات الحرس الجُمُهوري،
وأربعة ألوية من الحرس الجُمهوري الخاص،
وخمسة ألوية من الفدائيين، ولواءين من القوات الخاصة.
وبرز العراق في نهاية الحرب العراقية الإيرانية،
كأكبر سوق للسلاح في العالم،
فقد كان يشتري أسلحة من مَصادر مُختلفة ومَتعددة،
ووفقاً لتقييم أعدته الهيئة الأميركية لمراقبة ونزع الأسلحة،
أستورد العراق ما قيمته 24 مليار دولار
من المعدات العسكرية بين عامي 1981 و1985.
بينما كانت القوات الجوية قرابة ال٢٠ ألف فرد،
ب٣١٦ مقاتلة،
وبرزت القوات البحرية ب٢٠٠٠ فرد
وجميع أنواع الأدوات والأسلحة للقوات البحرية
من زوارق وفرقاطات وسفن مضادة للألغام وغيرها،،،
كل هذه القوة كانت تمتلكها العراق
حتى سقوط صدام عام ٢٠٠٣،
حينها أعلن الحاكم المدني للعراق، بول بريمير،
حل القوات المسلحة العراقية وكذلك وزارتي الدفاع والإعلام،
وإلغاء العديد من أجهزة الأمن العراقية، ....
واليوم أصبح الجيش العراقي في المرتبة ال٥٧ عالميا،
والمرتبة ال٧ على مستوى الشرق الأوسط،
بقرابة٣٠٠ ألف فرد في القوات البرية،
ويملك ٤٠٠ دبابة، و٣٠٠ مقاتلة جوية،
لكن سلاح الجو العراقي أصبح ضعيفا جدا مقارنة بالدول الغربية
بل حتى أنه أضعف بكثير من  عدد من الدول العربية، ..
أما فيما يخص القوات البحرية فلا تمتلك أكثر من ١٠٠ قطعة بحرية
ولا تمتلك أي فرقاطة أو كاسحة ألغام، ومعظم أدواتها هي الزوارق السريعة،،،
فأين كان الجيش العراقي في عهد صدام وأين أصبح اليوم ؟
وكيف اختفى جيش صدام المرعب وأين ذهب السلاح
سيكون لنا في هذا فيديو آخر
ومن أجل أن نستمر بالنشر لاتنسى الاعجاب بالفيديو
والاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل الجرس ليلصلك كل جديد...